who's looking to get more consistent
High ticket sales for their coaching
consulting or course offer awesome
because I recently had a guy tell me
that he does not believe that one can
get high ticket sales every day on
autopilot so I decided to show you
exactly how it's done using low Adit
ticket offers in this video but before
we dive in my name is is Mals the 4-Hour
consultant and I help coaches
consultants and experts get high ticket
sales every day on autopilot you guessed
it through low and M ticket offers okay
so let's actually start with a stripe
screenshot here are the sales that I've
made yesterday and now let me explain to
you how they come in on autopilot so for
me I am turning leads into buyers by
using a a $24 product which is a low
ticket offer and then a percentage of
those purchase my 4we we Sprint the
4-Hour Consulting bundle which varies
from anywhere between $218 to $1,200
depending on the X's to me and then the
convinced buyers who loved those offers
will inquire to become clients for
$2,200 a month and purchase through
payment links now with that off the
plate let me actually show you how to
launch that for yourself in 24 hours or
less okay so let's actually start with
the end in mind and begin with the high
ticket offer like most of us when I
started online people told me to make it
in online world you need a high ticket
offer so little miles built one
eventually I figured out that those
suckers are pretty damn hard to sell and
that strangers aren't just going to hand
over 10K so I did what most people
do and kind of like trying to make that
offer easier to sell so I've added money
back guarantees I promised bigger
results and put more work on me and less
on decline by adding in Crazy
deliverables so very soon I had this
100K offer which I sold for 10K and sure
it was a lot easier to sell but also it
was very hard to deliver it took a ton
of time and a ton of effort and it was a
pain in the ass to scale so before I
knew it I had a sales team I have
fulfillment coaches little profits and
no cash in the
back okay so how does one avoid that
scenario and actually build a high
ticket offer that is easy to sell fun to
deliver and profitable to scale there
are three Simple Rules one make smaller
promises that are easier to keep even if
they aren't as sexy compared to your
competition then two design it in a way
so the promise can be delivered in two
days a week or less and three charge
what it is actually worth so here's my
exact High ticket offer that I'm selling
I'm charging $5,000
it's one live Workshop per month with
all of my clients it's two group calls
per week where I answer questions it's a
school Community for questions also
hosting all of the recordings of my
workshops and there are no other coaches
just me so people just get access to me
my total delivery time is two hand off
hours per week and clients actually get
better results through that offer than
they did back in the days with my
complicated offer now this isn't because
of the deliverables or the offer itself
but simply because of the quality of
clients that are inside the offer the
people that I am working with so how
does one sell unsexy offers that are't
promising the world that don't have a
money back guarantee to Quality clients
the key just never ever again attempt to
sell Colt leits a high ticket off offer
by using a model like this where we go
from lead magnet to zil's conversation
to high ticket CLI it's just incredibly
hard to sell those High ticket offers on
sales calls especially with the trust
ression we're in and the only way to
profitably do that is by again creating
offers that are easy to sell but a pain
in the ass to deliver so get rid of that
model and instead use a model like this
where you actually turn
leads into buyers first there as if you
would go and buy clothes you first try
them on and you convince yourself off
the product rather than having someone
else convince you of it and then have
your buyers inquire to become High
ticket clients it just makes the whole
thing so much easier
also it will recoup your marketing
Investments and a lot of cool stuff that
we'll dive in later in that video so now
that we spoke about your high ticket
let's actually build your ticket offer
think if mid ticket offers as a Sprint
while your high ticket offer is the
marathon they're usually priced anywhere
between like 200 bucks or $1,200 like it
doesn't really matter but the idea is
that we get customers to a point of of
no return let me give you an example my
Mt ticket offer is the 4-Hour Consulting
bundle and inside within 4 weeks I help
my customers build and launch their low
and M ticket off offers the goal is that
within those four weeks they cash flowed
an extra
$33,000 through those offers and now
have three ideal clients ready to
purchase the high ticket offer this is
my hypothesis and if that is
accomplished through my mitt ticket
offer there's going to be more momentum
flowing towards my high ticket offer
then there is backtracking and
forgetting everything that they've done
with me over the last 4 weeks so it's
almost like practically guaranteed that
at that point they will buy my high
ticket offer and all they need to buy it
is to use my payment link and pay for it
they don't need to speak to me to buy
that offer because they already
understand the Sprint and what's going
to happen inside so now we understand
the high ticket offer we understand the
mid ticket offer that gets us High
ticket clients now how do we get mid
ticket clients we do that through
through the low ticket offer let's piece
that together really quick the low
ticket offers are really simple they
basically just need to do one thing
which is solving a single problem in 7
days or less and the product must be
consumed in 3 hours or less in one
sitting so to create your own low ticket
offer here's a few questions that will
help you in doing so one of all the
problems that you're solving inside your
high ticket offer which one do people
most frequently come to you to solve
what parts of your work do clients and
students most love appreciate or
celebrate and what nagging issues can
you help fix in an afternoon somewhere
within those answers you'll actually
find your low ticket offer now in terms
of price range price is anywhere between
A1 to 49 bucks again it doesn't really
matter and I want you to not over
complicate this in my case I literally
just take the recordings of the
workshops that I do with my high ticket
clients once a month and those are my
low ticket offers right so that is also
why I actually do recommend all of my
clients to do one life Workshop a month
in their High ticket offer because it
just creates the entire Firepower for
your low ticket offers making the whole
thing so much easier because what you
actually do for your clients are
generally the best low ticket offers
getting you more of the clients that
you're already serving now here's how
all of this is actually coming together
so you're running traffic and that
traffic goes to your low ticket offer so
that we can turn that those browsers
that traffic into actual buyers that
purchase your low ticket offer now a
chunk of those by upsell through the
funnels you're setting up will actually
purchase your 4we Sprint for anywhere
between $200 to $1,200 and those people
inside the Sprint will then inquire to
become High ticket clients and what's
going to happen too is even people that
are purchasing your low ticket offer
will actually reach out and ask you for
your high ticket offer so you will start
getting high ticket clients on autopilot
that are simply clicking your payment
links and are purchasing now when it all
hits on all cylinders cylinders fires
and all cylinders you now have a high
ticket program for every single month
you are running workshops those
workshops become your low ticket offers
they all go right into your mid ticket
offer and if you're anything like me
someone who's creative who thinks of
many things that you could do for the
market just turn them into little ticket
offers before over committing to it and
creating like a whole program but that's
really it so if you want to build that
whole system for yourself and get high
ticket clients on Auto pallet every
single day then I'd recommend you to
actually check out the 4-Hour Consulting
bundle that'll help you launch those
offers I just explain to you before what
we're going to do inside so the link to
that is going to be somewhere around
this video I hope you're picking this up
it's a great product